Democratic congressman Adam Schiff is
chairman of the House Intelligence
Committee which is leading one of the
six impeachment investigations
he's on Capitol Hill where he's asked
for a meeting with that whistleblower
congressman good morning I want to start
with this CBS News has learned that the
whistleblower complaint involves more
than just that Ukraine phone call what
more can you tell us about the
whistleblower well I can't tell you I
think about the whistleblower I don't
even know the identity of the
whistleblower and we don't at this point
know whether the reporting is correct
that the complaint involves this call or
involves as you say multiple acts but I
think one thing is clear this one
conversation of the president's and this
one witness if it does involve this
subject matter is not the some toll of
the story after all Rudy Giuliani has
admitted as the president's legal
ambassador apparently to Ukraine that he
also was pressuring Ukraine to
manufacture dirt on Joe Biden so there
may have been many interactions by the
President or people like Rudy Giuliani
to apply this pressure campaign even as
the president states withheld vital
military aid to an ally that's at war
with Russia and this is why this is of a
wholly different level I think most of
us have concluded and that is the
national security of the United States
is very much at risk here when the
president would use military assistance
to an ally as a cudgel effectively even
as he is trying to get them to
manufacture dirt on his opponent
congressman the president has denied all
wrongdoing he's also acknowledged doing
certain things that the Democrats are
saying are already admission of guilt
but without having seen the
whistleblower complaint without having
seen a transcript of the call why are
you confident going forward with an
impeachment inquiry do you really think
there's evidence beyond what the
president has already said publicly well
what the president has said publicly is
damning enough I mean let's look at what
he said let's look at what his lawyer
has said they both admitted to
pressuring Ukraine to manufactured
on their opponent Joe Biden there's no
no rationalizing that no justifying that
that is a horrible abuse of the oath of
office in terms of what language he used
at this particular call that's only one
aspect of the evidence but here what the
president has already admitted the
president's acknowledgment of
withholding Ukraine aid the fact that he
would not even share with leaders of his
own party like Mitch McConnell the
justification the fact that when this
came to light he is now given shifting
explanations for why he withheld the aid
I think all of those facts which are
uncontested at this point compel us to
move down the path of a formal
impeachment inquiry and so we'll see
what the transcript has to say but if it
says merely what the president has
acknowledged that stemming enough you
know Mitt Romney said earlier that
basically the Democrats have gotten
ahead of their skis what would have been
wrong to Tony's point in waiting to see
what the documents showed before you did
this I I heard what you just said but
would it have been so bad to wait a
couple of days because the the thinking
now is that you're going to rally the
president's base no I mean the there was
no reason to wait for the reason that
this doesn't depend on what the
transcript says what the president has
already admitted is all we needed to
know that the president has told the
American people that yes I leaned on
Ukraine to manufacture dirt on my
opponent that is true regardless of what
this transcript if it is indeed a full
transcript has to show the fact that his
lawyer has said that his simile made
efforts to browbeat Ukraine into doing
their political work into intervening
another election the fact that this
takes place after the president did this
as a candidate omits one thing when the
president sought Russian help when his
son met with the Russians to receive
Russian help during the last election
but now using the power of this office
in a way that damages our national
security that is a wholly different
order of magnitude of seriousness
congressman and not something that we're
content to wait about well cover from
them quickly what is the timeline now
for this well the timeline
you know we feel a real sense of urgency
you know in fact as the inspector
general observed about this
whistleblower complaint this matter is
urgent it is not one that can wait and
so we're gonna move expeditiously now I
fully expect as we have seen before the
administration to Stonewall and in fact
I think the only reason that the
whistleblower is being permitted to come
into the committee the only reason the
president is indeed releasing the
transcript is because of the club of
impeachment congressman said we've not
taken that step I don't think they would
have relented
congressman Schiff thank you very much
we look forward to looking at that
transcript if it's released today